From original cast members to newcomers like
Callie Haverda and Reyn Doi, here's where
you've seen these "That '90s Show" stars before.
Kurtwood Smith is back as Eric's no-nonsense
father, Red Forman.
However, this time he'll be laying down the
law with his granddaughter Leia.
In an exclusive interview with Looper, Smith
expressed his excitement at returning to the
franchise and noted that he and his on-screen
wife Debra Jo Rupp easily fell back into step on set.
Since Red and Kitty agreed to stay in Point
Place in the finale of "That '70s Show," viewers
were finally able to catch up on what these
characters have been up to between 1980 and
1995 in season one of "That 90s Show."
During the 16-year interim, Smith has added
a number of film and TV credits to his varied filmography.
Notably, the actor has starred in the second
season of Marvel's "Agent Carter" as Vernon
Masters, a role that was written with him
in mind.
He then went on to guest star in a handful
of popular series like "Suits" and "Jupiter's
Legacy," before having a role on the Hulu
mini series, "The Dropout." Smith plays David
Boies in the Amanda Seyfried-led biographical crime drama, which was nominated for six Primetime Emmy Awards.
Fans of "That '70s Show" might have also noticed
him playing Old Man Peterson in "The Ranch,"
another Netflix comedy led by co-star Ashton
Kutcher.
Joining Red for the difficult task of keeping
Leia in line is his wife, Kitty.
Debra Jo Rupp reprises her role as the fan-favorite
character who is best known for being something
of a mother figure to all of Eric's friends.
Rupp continued to work on family-orientated
shows when "That '70s Show" wrapped, taking
roles in shows like "Better with You," "This
Is Us," and "I Feel Bad."
Rupp's extensive TV credits also include guest
stints on other popular series like "Hart
of Dixie" and "Grey's Anatomy."
In 2021, she joined the Marvel Cinematic Universe
as a series regular in "WandaVision," the
first installment of Marvel's Phase 4.
"That '90s Show" viewers might recognize Rupp
in her role as Westview Citizen Sharon Davis, aka.
Mrs. Hart.
Speaking about her role in the miniseries,
Rupp told Looper in an exclusive interview
that her sitcom and theater background is
really what sealed the deal on her getting
the part.
Although she was initially hesitant, Rupp
loved being a part of "WandaVision," saying:
"We had such a lovely time."
The first and most important addition to the
new cast of "That '90s Show" is Callie Haverda,
who takes on the role of Eric and Donna's
teenage daughter, Leia.
Texas native Haverda has been acting since
she was six years old, telling her high school
paper The Westwood Horizon in a 2022 interview,
Haverda is best known for her role as Lala
Marks in the Hulu crime drama "Shut Eye" in 2017.
"That '90s Show" is undoubtedly Haverda's
biggest role to date, though, and a defining
moment in the actor's career.
She told The Horizon that her career previously
lacked direction, and finding Leia's character
sparked something in her, saying,
"That '90s Show" is all about Leia connecting
with her own group of friends, beginning with
the rebellious Riot grrrl, Gwen.
Played by Ashley Aufderheide, Gwen is Leia's
next-door neighbor, and the two hit it off immediately.
In fact, Gwen literally lives in Donna's old
house, since Bob Pinciotti moved to Florida
at the beginning of the '80s.
"You found the people who don't fit in, and
I am their queen."
Prior to joining the cast, Aufderheide's biggest
roles included ABC's sci-fi mystery-drama
"Emergence" an indie flick "Infinitely Polar
Bear," which stars Mark Ruffalo and Zoe Saldana.
In 2020, she also featured in the British
fantasy film "Four Kids and It."
Gwen isn't the only next-door neighbor Leia
gets to know.
She soon befriends Gwen's fun-loving brother
Nate, who is played by Maxwell Acee Donovan.
Nate and Gwen have an interesting dynamic
on the show, and somewhat replicates Eric
and Laurie's relationship since Leia is an
only child.
Viewers might know the actor behind Nate's
big smile from his starring role in the Disney
Channel series, "Gabby Duran & The Unsittables."
Donovan plays the titular character Gabby's
best friend Wesley Presley and he credits
the comedy series for making his dream of
an acting career a reality.
Prior to bagging this longstanding main role,
Donovan had some smaller supporting roles,
such as the TV miniseries "Greenlit," and
the Zoey Deutch and Nicholas Braun-led rom-com,
"Good Kids."
Newcomer Sam Morelos stars in "That '90s Show"
as the ambitious and intelligent teenager Nikki.
There's a lot more than meets the eye when
it comes to Nikki.
Deadline described her, as having, quote,
"more rebellion than a frustrated debutante,
and her boyfriend Nate can scratch that itch."
Nikki is Morelos' first TV role, but she's
previously starred in a couple of short films,
including "Forgetting Nobody" and "Extraordinary
Night."
When filming Season 1 of "That '90s Show"
concluded, Morelos took to Instagram to celebrate
the experience and everything leading up to
it.
Alongside some behind-the-scenes content,
she wrote:
Mace Coronel plays the flirty aspiring videographer
Jay, another member of Leia's gang, as well
as her love interest.
"Hey girl."
With more than a decade of acting experience
behind him, "That '90s Show" viewers will
likely have seen Coronel before.
He got his start playing R.J.
Forrester in "The Bold and the Beautiful,"
before starring in the 2014 TV movie, "Santa Hunters."
However, Coronel is probably best known for
starring in Nickelodeon's comedy series "Nicky,
Ricky, Dicky & Dawn."
He played Dicky, one of the titular quadruplets
of the Harper family, but he left abruptly
in the middle of production on the fourth
season.
He announced his departure in a since-deleted
Instagram post, which explained that it was
a mutual decision so he could focus on other
roles.
As promised, Coronel diversified his filmography,
and he went on to star in short films and
some miniseries.
He said on his Instagram that he hoped the
2019 short film "Pocket," which is a commentary
on social media and having the world in your
pocket, would be an "eye-opening” film for audiences.
He followed this up with roles in "Wireless"
and Colin Kaepernick and Ava DuVernay's drama
"Colin in Black and White."
As beloved as "That '70s Show" is, parts of
it wouldn't be accepted today and that includes
its lack of LGBTQ characters and storylines.
While the short-lived spinoff "That '80s Show"
had a bisexual character, Reyn Doi will play
the TV franchise's first openly gay character,
Ozzie.
Doi has been acting since 2017, bagging his
first job as a dancer in a Sonos commercial.
He quickly racked up a number of credits in
commercials and short films, before playing
Takeshi, the son of an extradited fugitive,
in an episode of the crime-action series "S.W.A.T."
in 2020.
His big breakout role came the following year,
though, when he played Yoyo in "Barb and Star
Go to Vista Del Mar."
He plays Kristen Wiig's sidekick, but as the
New York Post notes, Doi quickly steals the show.
At the same time, Doi was working on the Nickelodeon
family comedy "Side Hustle," and the TV movie
"Adopted."
Actor and musician Olivia Sanabia has a supporting
role in "That '90s Show" as Serena.
She is best known for starring in the Amazon
Studios series "Just Add Magic" from 2016
to 2019, in which she plays Kelly Quinn in
51 of the show's 52 episodes.
While filming the third season of the magical
dramedy, Sanabia started working on the Disney
Channel series "Coop & Cami Ask the World."
When that show ended, she bagged guest roles
in a variety of other notable series.
You might recognize her as Luanne in "Country
Comfort," McKenna in "This Is Us," and Hailey
from "Colin in Black and White."
Viewers may also know Sanabia as a singer.
Her discography includes three original singles
— "Star Crossed," "Evergreen," and "The
Train" — the latter of which is a particularly
important message about accepting your differences.
Sanabia explained in a 2020 interview with
Girls' Life,
Topher Grace was the leading man in "That
'70s Show" before he departed ahead of Season
8 to star in "Spider-Man 3."
He did, however, return for the series finale
and conclude his story by getting back together
with Donna.
Grace's early exit is one of the sore points
of "That '70s Show," and to add insult to
injury, "Spider-Man 3" was largely panned,
with director Sam Raimi even calling the film awful.
"I'm gonna put some dirt in your eye."
It somewhat put the brakes on Grace's rising
star, but he has since gone on to enjoy big
movie success.
Since the 2007 superhero film, Grace has starred
in a handful of notable features like "Interstellar,"
"American Ultra," "War Machine," "Delirium,"
and BlacKkKlansman.
He's also found a permanent home on the TV
comedy "Home Economics" which follows Grace
as Tom, the oldest of three siblings who are
all in different financial situations.
Speaking of family shows, returning to the
world of Point Place again for "That '90s
Show" felt like a family reunion for Grace.
He told ET,
"That '90s Show" had a lot of work to do to
connect the dots between the finale of "That
'70s Show" and 1995, including Donna's story
of raising Leia and becoming a writer.
Laura Prepon certainly believes it does her
character justice, telling Us Weekly before
season 1 was released,
Donna has clearly been busy over the last
decade and a half, and so has Prepon.
After playing the red-haired tomboy for eight
years, Prepon took on the lead role in the
NBC sitcom "Are You There, Chelsea?"
Of course, "That '90s Show" viewers probably
know her best from her long stint as the dark-haired
maven Alex Vause in "Orange Is the New Black."
While filming the comedy-drama, Prepon also
appeared as Cathy in the 2016 psychological
thriller "The Girl on the Train."
With Eric and Donna coming back, why not try
to get as much of the whole gang back together
as possible?
Mila Kunis confirmed her return to the franchise
as Jackie Burkhart in an interview with Access
Hollywood, where she explained the different
relationship dynamics which have taken place
off-screen since the finale.
Although Jackie and Wilmer Valderrama's character,
Fez, were together when the series ended,
everyone knew she was meant to end up with
her husband Ashton Kutcher's character, Kelso.
Before season 1 even came out, the actor let
slip a few details about her part in the upcoming
series, including the fact that Jackie and
Kelso are now married with a kid.
Since 2006, Kunis has starred in a string
of movies.
She's been in romantic comedies like "Forgetting
Sarah Marshall," and "Friends With Benefits."
She's been in action comedies like "The Spy
Who Dumped Me" and romantic action-adventure
films like "Jupiter Ascending."
She's also been in more dramatic features
like the Academy Award nominated-film, "Black
Swan," and 2022's "Luckiest Girl Alive."
As well as this, Kunis has voiced the character
of Meg Griffin in "Family Guy" since Season
2 in 1999.
"That '90s Show" is one of only a few times
she's shared the screen with Kutcher since
the original series.
Kunis said of returning to the show with Kutcher,
Ashton Kutcher credits "That '70s Show" with
kick-starting his career and told Variety
in a 2022 interview that the reason he and
his wife Mila Kunis are returning for the
spinoff is so that they can pay homage to
that.
He said,
In the years between the original series and
"That '90s Show," Kutcher has enjoyed a very
successful film and television career.
Viewers will no doubt recognize him from one
of his roles in romantic comedy films such
as "What Happens in Vegas," "Valentine's Day,
"Killers," and "No Strings Attached."
From 2011 to 2015 Kutcher also starred in
the beloved comedy series, "Two and a Half
Men," replacing lead Charlie Sheen.
While speaking on the "WTF With Marc Maron"
podcast, Kutcher explains that he owes much
of his comedic success to "That '70s Show"
creator Bonnie Turner, who taught him the,
quote, "rhythms of comedy."
From 2016 to 2020 Kutcher focused on TV, namely
his role as Colt Bennett in Netflix's family
dramedy, "The Ranch."
Kutcher has since returned to features, starring
in the 2022 black comedy "Vengeance" alongside
B.J. Novak, Boyd Holbrook, Issa Rae, Dove Cameron,
and John Mayer.
Wilmer Valderrama is best known for playing
foreign exchange student Fez in all eight
seasons of "That '70s Show."
Since it ended, Valderrama has been the architect
of his career, intentionally choosing varied
projects in different genres to work on.
Some of his notable credits include "From
Prada to Nada," "From Dusk til Dawn: The Series,"
"Minority Report," and "NCIS."
Speaking to People in 2022, Valderrama explained
the responsibility he felt during the early
stages of his career as a Latino actor.
He shared,
"But I do need you to lower that weapon."
"Please and thank you."
Fans may also recognize Valderrama from his
recurring role in "The Ranch," in which he
plays Umberto, and his five-episode guest
stint on "Grey's Anatomy" as patient Kyle Diaz.
However, "That '70s Show" still holds a big
place in his heart.
In fact, according to The Wall Street Journal,
Valderrama still owns the original Vista Cruiser
from the series, which he purchased for $500.
Although 'That 90s Show" reveals that Fez
didn't end up with Jackie because of her feelings
for Keslo, things are looking up for the owner
of a successful salon chain.
Hopefully his new flame, Andrea Anders' character,
Sherri, and him can make it work in the long run!
"That '70s Show" alum Don Stark is also returning
for the spinoff in a supporting role as Donna's
dad Bob Pinciotti.
Speaking about his return to the set with
Entertainment Weekly, Stark said:
All the young people who were in the new cast
were terrific, and it mirrored what it was
like when we started."
Viewers will of course know that Stark is
not returning with his on-screen wife, Tanya
Roberts, who sadly passed away in 2021.
However, his return in episode 6 of season
one is a delight, especially his karaoke performance
at his granddaughter's birthday party.
Since 2006, Stark has been busy guest-starring
on a variety of TV series.
His knack for comedy has helped him secure
roles in the likes of "Curb Your Enthusiasm,"
"Shameless" and "Dollface."
He's also used his comedic acting chops to
play Jules Podell in 2018's "Green Book,"
and Sol in the star-studded rom-com "Café
Society."
Actor, comedian, and musician Tommy Chong
will forever be known to "That '70s Show"
fans as veteran-turned-hippy stoner Leo.
The beloved member of the Cheech & Chong comedy
duo was an important member of the show's
supporting cast.
Although he wasn't present in every season,
he often showed up just in time to make some
interesting observations relating to the lives
of Eric and his friends.
He also took Hyde under his wing, giving him
a job at the Foto Hut.
"That '90s Show" just wouldn't be complete
without an appearance from Leo, but thankfully,
Chong has returned and made a fitting comeback.
In fact, he hilariously doesn't seem to pick
up on many of the callbacks to "That 70s Show"
or even remember Kitty and Red.
Since the original series ended in 2006, Chong
has been a vocal marijuana activist.
Alongside his 2006 documentary "A/k/a Tommy
Chong" which chronicles this, the actor often
plays activists or characters who use drugs
freely, just like Leo.
More recently, Chong played stoner Hubert
Wilson in the "Raising Hope" Season 4 episode,
"The One Where They Get High."
Viewers might also recognize Chong from his
appearance on "The Masked Singer" in 2019
where he competed on the reality singing show
as a Pineapple.